a landmark near the airport turning 80
next week K news out reporter Brian will
gives us an inside Glimpse at the
history of the little Church of the West
[Music]
it's a long Las Vegas Boulevard just a
stone's throw away from the famous Las
Vegas sign
but this Chapel hasn't always been in
this spot
three times before settling into its
current location in 1996 the chapel was
built in 1942 and is the oldest existing
structure on the Strip
This is where Betty Grable and Harry
James got married in 1943. this is where
Judy Garland said I do in 1965 and home
to the Viva Las Vegas film where Elvis
Presley got married in 1964 in the film
but it's also home to more than a
hundred thousand happy couples who've
said I do here over the last 80 years
the drapes used to be like a sheepskin
Greg Smith bought the chapel 40 years
ago a perfect fit for him we would
Cruise the strip in high school and
you'd see like a little church right in
the middle of the strip with this huge
green belt and uh you know happy people
and and I was already in the wedding
business like that's a that's a great
chapel and there was a wedding here
almost every day you want you know you
want that day to be special for
everybody now hopefully you know we will
be here you know forever
other notable celebrities who got
married there include Angelina Jolie and
Billy Bob Thornton the little Church of
the West will host its 80-year
celebration Monday afternoon